oh woof oh I threw my back out oh here
we go again
last time that was the case too
um well a couple there have been a
couple developments on my breaking uh my
body breaking down yeah
welcome back Dr Drew are we going now
yeah let's roll right into this okay by
the way thank you for the coffee
absolutely yeah and uh and I use your
bathroom here like this is on my mind
right now because I just walked out of
the bathroom Okay and uh it's a pristine
bathroom with nice subway tile
everything's clean and the toilet seat
is down okay and I thought oh this is
set up for women this is a this is a
nice bathroom and I thought
how different that is than when I used
to go visit Adam and Jimmy at the man
show a bunch of men writers and you'd
stand of course they had urinals all
over the place and you stand at the
urinals and when you looked up there was
like a mound of snot Rockets oh my God
like like who could get the biggest most
craziest no and oh yes oh yeah and I
didn't dare go into the actual toilets
that's just at the latrine I don't
believe that men who were like paid a
salary would do something like that like
well it's not only paid men that do that
I have news for you oh man do that I
shouldn't act so shocked because I did
live with a person for 10 years who
would collect his um fungus shavings
from his feet and make these little
meatballs from it and he would keep them
as little figurines by the bathtub I've
always had concerns about him now I have
Grace
I have to say like male bathrooms have
really traumatized me like yes they
should yes like in college I was around
like fraternities and stuff and like
those kinds of guys and I just vowed to
myself from that point forward I would
never live in a house or an apartment
that ran out of toilet paper oh yeah
that's my bottom line in life I'm just
never running out of toilet paper I'm a
toilet paper person but that's a Titanic
I just toilet paper Panic yeah it sounds
like it rolls off the tongue do you have
TPP
it is a condition I find like a lot of
Americans have that didn't we Americans
well yeah because in in the Philippines
we just mechanically wash with our hands
in a Thabo which is uh yeah so even if
we pee like you always see me walk in
with a water bottle well and some
countries have a sort of a weird thing
about touching back there you have to
use the hose and nothing else right and
those hoses have you ever seen what
she's talking about no they come out
with they could they could put out at
least a one-story fire
those things yeah I also have a theory
that I think that only men should have
to wash their hands after they use the
bathroom no matter what number it was I
think that women like wipe and do
everything and they they don't need to
wash they're ninjas yeah they're
absolute anal ninjas that's absolutely
what happens perineal ninja ninjas to be
fair you're right because I don't take
sloppy shits we certainly do men that's
our special
how did we I led us into this I can't
believe it let's keep going
native has a new limited edition line
the candy shop collection like all
Native products they are thoughtfully
formulated to keep us feeling and
smelling deliciously fresh all day long
and right now go to nativedio.com trash
Tuesday or use promo code trash Tuesday
at checkout to get a sweet 20 off your
first order that's nativedeo.com Tuesday
or use promo code trash Tuesday at
checkout for 20 off your first order
thank you to our sponsor rocket money do
you know how much your subscriptions
cost most Americans think they spend
around 80 a month on subscription but
the total is actually closer to 200 if
you don't know exactly how much you're
spending every month you need rocket
money stop throwing your money away
cancel unwanted subscriptions and manage
your expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday that's
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday this show
is sponsored by betterhelp when you're
at your best you can do great things but
sometimes life gets you bogged down and
you may feel overwhelmed around or like
you're not showing up in the way you
want to if you want to live a more
empowered life therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today
to get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp help.com trash Tuesday you
guys I'm finally coming to Miami I
cannot wait get tickets at Esther
andice.com I will see you soon yo what's
up sluggies what a great episode today
I'm so excited for you guys to watch it
uh you can also come see me do stand up
live I'm gonna be in Washington DC at
the comedy Loft at the end of February
I'm going to be in Seattle Washington
March 10th and 11th Tampa Florida March
17th and 18th Toronto Canada I'm going
to be in Raleigh North Carolina Salt
Lake City Utah and a lot of other places
just go to annieleterman.com shows and
you can always see a little extra Annie
on my solo podcast anniewood that you
can watch on YouTube every Thursday I do
a Premiere where I will live chat with
you guys it comes out 12 Eastern or nine
Pacific it's so fun to do I love you
guys can't wait to see you
one of my goals for today is because
last time you were here you left and you
were very like depleted I was affected
by yeah I hope that you don't leave here
today maybe that's why I started with
the bathroom talk yeah just to see if we
could start off on the right foot and
not have me sucked into the Vortex come
on but no that but that's something I
enjoy doing which is is opening to other
people's things and you were talking
about some very significant things and
so I was feeling it and at the end of
feeling stuff like that I I wasn't
always a feeling person did I mention
this last time I remember no no so I'd
go to therapy for a long time and one of
my work of therapy was feelings were way
off in the distance and I couldn't
connect them very easily because I had a
abusive mom and all the that we did I
talked about myself yeah yeah and
um and so I was very focused on other
people which is a it's a nice asset to
be able to do that but I couldn't feel
anything or could feel anxiety and anger
and that's about it and uh through many
many many years of therapy I got very
connected up I had really good
Psychotherapy and was then able to offer
that to other people as something is
sort of a receptive you know sort of
capacity that I had and it's been very
very rewarding it's a rich rewarding
thing to do for people but it makes you
tired it just makes you tired and and by
the way I like in Celebrity Rehab uh
soon so normally when you when you're
working with patients on a deep level
like that you have to you have to you
can't do too many of them in a row you
can't do too many patients in a row in a
day and you have to take time off you
have to go do other things a day here or
there
with Celebrity Rehab all 10 came in I
just see all 10 every day and it never
stopped and so I by about day four my
mechanism I would notice just didn't
work that well it just kind of just
shuts down when it gets too tired how do
you recharge from that because one thing
I've learned recently in my just recent
life experiences like I need to start to
prioritize rest days and I've even like
written in my journal like reminding
myself rest days are as valuable as work
days and I'm curious like how do you
recharge
or do you have advice for that I mean I
think those are very individual things I
I never give my myself a chance I just
kept going yeah uh and I would what I
tended to do was to grind through but I
would always try to make time for Sleep
which didn't always work uh and some
form of physical activity and that that
seemed to be enough because even when
I'm you know working out or something
that's a rest period you know I that's
my sort of meditative period yeah so for
me I was able to grind through that way
but and fortunately the way my days were
sort of naturally
organized I would I wouldn't be doing
too many too much of that intensive work
day after day it just that's the way I
was I had a partner that would go in on
one day or most most of the weekdays in
fact I do love the concept of looking at
exercise or physical activity like a
restful period because at least I know
when I'm doing it I'm like this is
self-care I'm doing this because I love
myself because you know I like myself
and all that
um I love yoga by Cassandra yeah
earlier
yeah I think of exercise is like not I
have to do it I get to do it oh my God
it exercise is really key for me sorry
same and you can there's always a
pattern you can always tell if I'm
having consecutively bad days that
there's a good chance I just have not
worked out in a while I I for sure that
affects me for sure but when you say bad
days what do you mean
um sluggish unmotivated
um feeling like you know there's like
the world is
um heavy on my shoulders I cannot like
simple tasks around the house I don't
feel like doing
um so that that's usually associated
with whether or not I've you know done
nice things for myself and one of that
is exercise or diving or getting in the
water or doing some sort of like
physical stuff I think I need an update
on you because I really don't know
what's been going on oh yes and I called
Bobby a couple times he does not return
my call he doesn't even he promised on
stage he would reconnect in the morning
I mean I literally he got down on his
knees at one point or did I get on my
knees who was it it was on his knee yeah
yeah I remember somebody's knees and
promising and
um the town and uh and he seemed good
then and then I something happened with
you guys and I don't know what has
happened I hope everybody's good are you
well we broke up about
um almost a year ago but we weren't
public about it for a couple more months
um but it's been a long time coming we
were in couples therapy for two years it
was a very slow burn of a breakup so
really what I'm interested in do you
guys are you each considering yourself
single now yeah you're single
everything's good you're sure and that
he's seeing a lot he's really like
having a good time
a lot yeah a lot a lot and a part of me
is like oh my God how is he doing that I
I anything you would want to do that or
um that's what I wanted to ask you I
have a really difficult time with
casually dating
having sex casually I like to really
connect with someone and kind of have
the feeling that there's a mutual liking
of each other before I have sex so
and I'm jealous of the other side I'm
jealous of Bobby or how about women that
can do that yes there are plenty of
women that can do that or but but they
in my experience most women that
celebrate that if end up sort of
depleted it ends up men don't get
depleted by that they can get sort of
but I see men doing is getting is
hurting people and then getting and then
feeling really bad about that uh but
women actually get depleted by making
themselves so vulnerable and then
nothing right so it's to me and and by
the way you're not 17 you know what I
mean it's it's but the point is you're
an adult and so that's a more adult kind
of move which is I'd rather have
something of substance but what is uh so
if we've been broken up for almost a
year or right around a year like what is
a protocol for when someone is ready to
jump into another relationship or is
that just on an individual basis it's
not an individual cases but I think
generally sorry I got something in my
throat today generally I think it's a
mistake to jump into another one I think
really what you got to do you know
there's a there's a lot of the process
of socializing and dating has been taken
away
right we just we're either hooking up or
we're getting a relationship when in
fact what's healthiest is spending some
time with people maybe going about for a
while getting to know them who Am I who
are you how do I understand myself in
relation to this person what do I like
not like and then 10 other people that I
go you know just hang out with spend
time with to see how I fit and what I
like and don't like you when you've been
in one kind of relationship for a long
time particularly one that
if there's any traumatic bonding in it
you're just going to do the same thing
all over again yeah right isn't that
what's going to happen yeah or you may
go the opposite direction which is
really the same direction you know it's
the do you don't want to flip the flip
the coin over you want to you want to
sort of get get a little broader and
clearer about as we said we talked about
this last time you know not so much
lightning bolts right that's so exciting
but also if you can't tolerate somebody
they're too boring you'll feel boring
and uncomfortable and really a kind of
person that you should be able to be
with that's like you can't handle it
that's the bring that to the therapist
oh okay because Esther and I have talked
about this a lot and we wonder because
we've always been girls with boyfriends
always have we've always been in Long
relationships and there never really is
uh more than a couple months in between
relationships would you say us too yeah
and I feel safer in relationships but is
that something I have to maybe look into
yes it's kind of a codependency it's
it's serial monogamy okay and this is
what I and I'm not saying that's bad I'm
saying that you might there might be a
richer territory for you to explore more
meaningful for you more success more
richer a richer relationship for you
okay because my instinct now knowing
that and being in therapy is really just
being alone yeah and not that's that's
sort of anorectic right but I'm not I'm
really struggling because let's say like
I'm seeing somebody
I I know that I'm not ready I don't feel
ready but I also don't feel safe not
fully going you know what I mean like I
just want to go there already yes that's
that's the job is to not do that and
maybe one way I know some people do that
by just making sure they're dating lots
of different people and filling their
time not jumping into their relationship
right away like I know now that I have
to pause and say okay like I'm not ready
for this but Esther it's been
like I just can't even imagine because
when I like someone I know right away
and they're like let's go like let's go
let's move in same like there's just no
world where I can hold it back and in
fact like in early days of relationships
not just the current one but like before
I've in my head I've had to be like
I really have to stop myself from saying
out loud I love you please don't leave
me please don't leave me like literally
I say that yeah in my head I've said
that and so yeah the thought of
pulling back in fact like it's [__] up
but I think the only way I could really
do that is if I had other connections
well that's what I'm saying those
connections don't have to be deep but
just distractions other other
experiences with other people where
you're assessing yourself and others
which I could now see how that is very
valuable and beneficial because now I'm
in a place in my relationship where I
have a lot of social connections outside
of it and that's great it's great like
it's so great for my relationship that I
go and get dinner with this friend on
this night and do this and that like so
the relationship that you got sucked
right into and jumped into well I sucked
it all up wherever you get there it was
all me
but it's it's hard and it and it can and
again in today's world it's very [__]
up how you know people are exploiting
each other and you're not really sure
what people's motives are and it's it I
I'm glad I'm not dating well what are
your thoughts then on just prolonging a
situationship because if I'm not
situationship right because it's that
middle ground of you know casually
dating and then being fully in a
committed monogamous relationship so we
kind of just drag out we do nice things
together we you know there's definitely
deep feelings there but because I'm not
ready I I in my head I shouldn't be in a
committed relationship so the label
isn't there and so I I don't know like
oh I know a lot of young people are
opting to be in situationships
I think one of the easy ways again the
the way to avoid that it seems to me is
don't have sex until way down the line
right because that automatically
intensifies everything it just
intensifies everything right yeah or or
if my doors are always open well but
very quickly I understand but but then
maybe
I don't know how you manage this maybe
do that with more than one person just
so you don't get too deeply but then who
knows listen it's I I think the exercise
is about boundaries right that's we're
talking about here we're talking about
how to how to be still yourself and not
merge with another person and sexuality
is a lot of merging activity it's it's
you know where you lose body boundaries
even yeah and you like that and that's
right people like that but you're gonna
if you want to change this you got to
kind of practice
not doing that you know for a while
I'm not saying for a year even I'm
saying this for a few months or if you
know just to see how it goes and and in
the meantime you you know in your mind
there's so much good porn out there
relax you're gonna be fine you're gonna
you're gonna be okay uh that that in
your mind you're gonna be able to sort
of
you know experience lots of different
people and hold your boundaries as part
of an evaluation process where you will
choose somebody to go a little further
with okay okay and then whether that
goes further than just a situation that
that's a hard question to answer this is
good to know yeah I think where you are
already it's it seems odd to say on one
hand I'm all the way in I'm deeply
involved with this but we're not gonna
put a label on it that doesn't feel
genuine yeah it's I yeah it's maybe a
little [__] up on my phone well I
didn't say [__] up I just said you're
already in you're already there yeah you
know and I understand now you're like
you're like trying to push your way back
no no no no no you're like slightly and
let's see look don't judge yourself so
harshly stop it okay you guys are all
like there's no perfect anything right
we're just talking about how to optimize
how to make things as good as possible
I'm glad that you said that don't judge
yourself because I am really trying to
be a lot nicer to myself I want to be
friends with myself I want to support
myself like I and I'm working on this
thing where when I feel something that
would normally I'd be like oh I can't
believe I feel that I can't believe I'm
sad about that like I'm trying to just
be like I notice that that's making me
sad and instead of rather than laying
the judgment on top of it yeah
you gotta you gotta wait about 10 more
minutes we're into it here dude
somebody else can talk
yeah who was molested who do we forget
no no we're talking about boundaries in
relationships no no diddles yet but we
should go right into that we did the
diddling thing last time I was here
Infinity diddle okay so this is yeah
you're right oh that's a really cute
band name Infinity diddle Infinity
doodle so let's finish where we were I
feel like I'm just back to the
self-judgment you know people throw
around a lot of judgmental terms about
themselves and other people these days
everyone knows what personality
disorders are on this kind of thing I
think you and I talked about this that I
I get very disturbed by people being
pejorative with labels because it for
instance particulars it pertains to
personalities they're all adaptive in
some way that's why they exist they have
assets and liabilities and to say oh
somebody's obsessed with compulsive if
they're an engineer or doctor that kind
of obsessed compulsion is extremely
effective very useful maybe a problem in
relationships or you can't get the
feelings but even narcissist if you're
you know at War and he's he's out there
in front with a sword that's the guy you
want out there the guy feels invincible
and so yeah it can be kind of hard in
relationships sometimes there are some
liabilities that come with it but don't
think about anything you think about who
you are and was yours all good or all
bad you know I do see
um the Silver Lining with having been
diddled
like there is
n't I mean Frozen ones hello
hotties we know how to rock a diaper
Esther wouldn't know Annie wait I'm glad
you guys are saying this because last
week we talked a lot about like I'm
discovering that I was emotionally
neglected as a child
and um
um
and like I find myself seeing the
positive in it a lot yeah so remember I
said I have I couldn't get into we were
talking about my [__] a little
earlier and I can't touch the feelings
but I was very focused on other people
well that focus on other people is laser
beam and so I can really now that I'm
connected to feelings I can use that to
feel what's going on with other people
before it was just the way I survived
like making sure my mom didn't yell at
me and my dad was an [__] you know
that kind of focus on others and
disconnecting from self particularly
during those developmental phases we're
supposed to be developing the connection
but later on that can be an asset I
learned how to cook uh because I had a
boyfriend that was would wake up so
angry so I learned a skill set I was
like I had to just like feed him food
and coffee so he wouldn't yell at me
like were you dating a lion or something
is it it's just like throw the meat in
honestly yes I'm very Carol Baskin too
her husband alive and well and like did
they actually find him or did she say
he's alive can we all agree that
whatever the [__] we read in the press
or on social media there's you can't
believe anything is there anything I
thought you were going to say can we all
agree whatever happened to him he will
be on a reality show with Dr drewitz
I bet you are no because he got prostate
cancer oh really yeah and he you've
massaged it and I I the attorney that
was in the show somehow I interviewed
him on something and so he was hey come
help uh have you seen his [__] uh I
didn't see it did you like go in it
so no I mean he was already diagnosed
his treatment options were and stuff
well he he wanted you probably right
he's like pretty Starfire
um no I didn't he didn't seem like it he
just but it did seem like somebody
pretending to be him you know it's like
when you talk to there's some people
that just are like if you talk to Arnold
Schwarzenegger you feel like you're
talking to a an image somebody's
imitating Arnold
Hollywood Boulevard version yeah yeah
and this and what's the tiger king's
name I'm playing Joe Exotics
what are you reading his [__] yes
Carlos is a formal relationship yeah
Joseph
not Wikipedia he's reading his LinkedIn
when it comes to Valentine's Day I have
to say I'm a candy girl not a flower
girl and don't you want your armpits to
smell like a candy shop yes yeah I want
Esther to lick my armpit I will
I'm ordering the new shoe my pit hair
thank you you guys know native as the
aluminum free deodorant I use it it's
the only thing that neutralizes my scent
in the most beautiful way I smell
delicious every day and now you can
smell like a candy shop and have Esther
like your armpits if you but can we just
say how awesome it is that finally
someone is giving the people what they
want
I want to smell like candy I know it's
really like about time you always smell
like your breath always smells like it
thank you your body smell like it and
Native deodorant checks a lot of boxes
72-hour odor protection naturally
derived ingredients and a smooth
residue-free application
and their ingredients are really nice
it's like coconut oil shea butter baking
soda I love the sour Berry belts I know
you love the gummy bear there's like
such good flavors and you guys now is
the time to make the switch from an
antiperspirant to Native when you visit
their site you can discover all their
fresh scents and maybe even try one of
their body washes they have a lot to
look at oh and their shampoos and
conditioners so good so detangling so
great and right now go to nativedeal.com
trash Tuesday or use promo code trash
Tuesday at checkout to get a sweet 20
off your first order that's
nativedeo.com trash Tuesday or use promo
code trash Tuesday at checkout for 20
off your first order
I love rocket money rocket money helps
me save money so I can spend more money
and Rocket money is formerly known as
true bill and it is a personal finance
app that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place over 80 percent of people have
subscriptions that they literally just
forgot about their streaming services
where you get it to watch one show and
then you forget there's free trials that
you never use I know I have like three
that I'm thinking of right now I have an
insect finder I mean I have everything
what is this what kind of insect is this
no I'm literally subscribed to every
streaming service that there is I I'm
subscribed to very embarrassing things
like really really humiliating weird and
so many different apps to edit I have
like 50 million editing apps I can't
keep up no the photo collage app
never-ending I know and they're from
like when have you even done a photo
collage in the past 10 years I've never
seen one from you that better have not
done any stop throwing your money away
and cancel unwanted subscriptions and
manage your expenses the easy way by
going to rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
that's rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
rocketmoney.com trash Tuesday
I have a question for you so I've
recently heard of this um
like type of depression concept or
whatever called The Long Goodbye Oh yeah
so great movie I want to explain this to
you and I I it resonated with me and
almost in a way where I'm like I have no
idea how to not feel this way but so
basically like this man shows a picture
of him and his uh his best friends at
his best friend's wedding and they're
all having fun and he goes this is a
picture this isn't a picture of me and
my best friends at their wedding this is
a picture of me thinking about how we've
all like the loss of our youth yeah so
yeah yeah so that's a trauma thing uh
and it's a narcissism thing not
narcissistic Disorder so much as
narcissistic you know the zone of
narcissism and some people will theorize
that
one of the one of the uncomfortable
prison or manifestations of narcissism
is longing for the end of longing
uh what like you're longing all the time
for that lost youth but you're longing
for that to go away it's you know you're
longing for and and it's uh you know
what I'm saying then it often like you
know Catcher in The Wa in the Rye was
this is pointed at that particular
phenomenon you know this kid that has to
grow up and can can't can't leave this
is this longing for this part of
yourself that you left behind well but I
don't like even when he says like oh
this is not a picture of my daughter on
her first day of school it's a picture
of me losing my little girl so you're
saying that's just
it all the dots always get connected
back to this loss
of self yeah because he said when this
wasn't a picture of my baby being born
he said this is a picture my [__]
getting blown out maybe saying goodbye
to that tidy
he's like
loss of his
um you Freedom or something or no he
said that the last he'll never feel the
happiness
always this connecting
yeah longing for this idealized time yes
I like doing the opposite where I get
excited for the future like thinking
about isn't that like I I had ton of
that I had a ton of that before I had
treatment really it just kind of went
away in treatment was it because you had
like
um trouble with your parents like that
you were yeah because you're like a good
time no no what it was as I come came to
understand it was that because
because I wasn't getting all right the
developmental process is about being
have seen yourself reflected back from
other important relationships parents we
kind of talked about this last time and
so I have a primary some feeling comes
up in me somebody that loves me examines
me assesses what's in my brain and then
reflects it back on their face and gives
me some vocal porosity to try to comment
okay or or a physical holding or
something to sort of manage that primary
feeling in and then sort of name it
identify it regulate it that's that's
the process of development when you have
abusive parents they go oh you drive me
crazy I need a drink or whatever or you
know why aren't you why don't you shut
up whatever it might be when the child
has a Primary Emotion they learn to
suppress it they not only don't get what
they need to identify and regulate it
they move away from it and that's
literally moving away from those parts
of yourself and that's what you're
longing for longing for the the the to
to bring reconnect with that you know
these they all the inner child Concepts
and stuff are all sort of built on that
it's just these parties these pieces
that get left behind because they're not
properly developed and your mom like
maybe not was wasn't
Bueno her face is kind of like she
doesn't have big animation on her face
so she may have not actually been like
neglecting you but you're not you didn't
get anything to like read off of didn't
get what's called second order
representation I think so right your mom
is always there my almost my my parents
were always but she's always like hmm
yeah because she's finished and so she
doesn't really have like a personality
don't come after us you finish people
yes she's just like this all the time I
don't know because I was trying to
figure out like I just I know that my
parents like neither my parents worked
the first seven years of my life like
they were always there yeah well they
were working they were always home oh
you guys fill me in and I was just my
mom was like a good caregiver but I'm
realizing based on like all these
attachment issues that I have that
clearly there was emotional neglect I
but I can't quite figure out like
exactly how or what yeah and that's and
that's very tough for children when they
can't get those needs met whether
there's actual physical neglect or
emotional neglect or abandonment
whatever it is those are pretty heavy
second order representation you have a
primary feeling yeah you have it the
other person examines it and then what
women do more so than men I'm sorry to
say but women bleed all over their
chairs they do and they blow out their
[__] when they
put that on a loop gentlemen we will be
fine
um but they where the [__] was I they
they women will literally with the small
muscles in their face around their mouth
and eyes will will literally reflect the
emotional state of the child
and it's sort of saying I understand it
here's what it is I can I I'm not
catching it it's not overcoming me but I
appreciate it here's what it is like
imagine what do you do a child comes I
rip my finger what do you do maybe not
you know
but yeah you go hmm yeah you not only
not only are you reflecting on your face
what what the child is experiencing but
it's sort of a pretend it's kind of an
exaggeration of the actual but they
start with these tiny muscles in the
face vocal porosity our voice our ear is
tuned into this socio-emotional exchange
system that allows for this to happen so
it's voice small muscles and then an
exaggerate once you really identified an
exaggerated signal that says I don't
have your feeling I'm I get your feeling
right yeah this makes so much sense
because my mom is just not like a lot of
people are physically this is not her
personality yeah but she's still like
feeling you she's just not yeah it's
like she read to me every night like way
too longer than I would like to admit
like Mom can Oh I thought you me like
that shoot the story went longer like
Mom it's time
we used to sleep for three hours my mom
wrapped it up I think I have
um lack of second order representation
at the gym what so I this week or when
I'm with a trainer he has a hard time
um figuring out how much weight I'm
supposed to carry because he says um I
don't show oh yeah like outwards so
you're you're young
on your face yeah so you're not good at
that if I'm doing Bulgarian split squat
say for instance he's looking at me and
he was like are you feeling the burn and
I'm dying I am like I in so so but he's
like you're looking like you're cruising
and I'm like I'm dying so you're in
therapy right now right yeah yeah does
she he she she does she give you a lot
of expression and emotion as you're as
you're saying and feeling things
um I think so okay pay attention to that
yeah pay attention to that and and see
if and ask for it even if that's what
you know you need and you'll you'll
start to see that you'll feel more
comfortable on your own doing the same
thing it's like just that that's
probably something you've gotten a
million times from your therapist hmm oh
my God and but that was a real
reflection that was a moment of
reflection and so that's what I'm
talking about yeah you have resting
bench phase
Bulgarian split Squad face you could
load up as many weights on me and I am
what is going on there she's emoting too
much Lila I'm like in such shock right
now because I you couldn't have picked a
better example for me to reflect back to
that I'm the exact opposite like yes we
know you do yoga once a week and I'm
really proud of it by Cassandra with
Cassandra every trainer I've ever worked
with like in fact that's why I'm so
locked in with the one I'm with now
because there I I have so many
complaints I'm like oh that I can't do
that and I'm really expressed that
they're like what's wrong like I'm just
the opposite like I always tell people
like I'm not shy whenever my needs are
not being met or like I'm struggling so
I'm gonna guess that whatever went on
with your mom is not as simple as the
way we're portraying it that yeah it's a
little more complicated I don't know
what it is but it's more complicated
than you suspect I suspect yeah okay
yeah but um wait what was I gonna say
well I'm thinking about your mom again
and was she how old is she now
and why did she come here well she was
born in Minnesota and would put a finish
to sand yeah and grew up Minnesota yeah
and your dad what's his deal uh grew up
in Chicago how'd they meet they met
working it's really this is the part I
keep wondering what you're talking about
where they don't work but they work what
happened here it's so it's like there's
a lot going on it's good though this may
help me well may if you do we want to we
don't want to out anybody but if there's
a way I can understand a little better
these people we call your parents well
you're watching I don't think it's worth
the show were they hippies no my dad was
his both of his parents passed away so
he lived in their house and was working
at the Cook County Treasury Office met
my mom they had they like fell in love
he didn't want to marry her and so they
broke she broke up with him and then
like two months later she she was upset
and then she got over the breakup and
called because she wanted to be friends
ends and then he was like so excited
that he called her and was like come
over and then that night he said that he
wanted to marry her and she was like no
you don't and then he's like I'll prove
it to you and then that's how I was
conceived so romantic this is why you
chased your ex-boyfriend because you're
still expecting him to go all right
let's do this yeah yeah
so baby right now but like my mom is a
very quiet and very perfectionist and
like caregiver clean everything is
perfect and try to put me in dresses and
I would be like I don't want to wear
this [__] dress when I was two were
they doll dresses probably and you said
[__] yes and my dad was like the big
personality and you know had like a
gambling issue here and there and yeah
interesting yeah had a half older sister
seven years older from my mom's first
marriage
I don't know I don't really but the my
like biggest headline that we haven't
talked about but that everyone is
probably sick of hearing is like I had
this traumatic High School breakup where
I've like really struggled to get over
it and like feel like everyone's Gonna
Leave Me I have really severe anxious
attachment like that sort of that's some
have to hearken back yeah somehow yeah
hurricane oh yeah how old were you uh
18. yeah it's just
this should be doing High School to each
other is just like yeah well it's just
you're like fake adults kind of you know
what I mean yeah but there's like
serious things I almost think it was
better back in the days when kids were
sort of kept you know under control a
little more and it's for their own good
not be not just you know not to be
uncool about it but just that they hurt
each other themselves they're not
developed enough to manage it I have a
question so like with the facial stuff
do you think that like plastic surgery
is affecting this like good question
Nicole Kidman's kids are like what does
my mom feel yeah it's possible yeah and
and I and I even wonder what also I
think to myself is how do these people
how do they act you know they're acting
and they can't use their facial muscular
right it's really interesting and the
period pieces you're like it's weird
like there wasn't even this type of
plastic that could yes explain what's
going on in your face
yeah I also think like every look or
every everything goes in and out of
style right and it's like that's why I
would rather just stay what I am than
commit to something that's not me but
also will be embarrassing later that I
did it but also don't you think like if
you do get a lot of work done your body
will adapt to a movie in another way
like your eyes will be probably more
expressive to your children and stuff
because it's like a natural I don't know
I don't know who's ever studied that to
my knowledge yeah cool well I'm going
back to school guys Esther will you
write my papers yes my mom quotes I
um Dr Drew I wanted to ask you about
something that's been
um plaguing me in the last 10 years and
that is the realization that I am a pro
product of two people who were very much
like loving and showed a lot of love to
each other but
um really if we think about it as a
predatory relationship my dad was 36
years older than my mom how old was she
when when it started she was 21 one and
he was in his late 50s
but he helped her too tell them how they
met he doesn't have to be Predator I
agree it's a little oh my God have you
guys seen MILF Manor speaking of prayer
oh my God I have to I'm not sure
holy [__]
but you but tell him the story but it's
he saved her yeah so it is a little bit
of a uh Captain Save A whole situation
yeah
my mom was previously married to a very
very abusive man and they were at a
wedding reception and my dad saw this
man drag my mom out by her hair and then
he followed them and he held this man at
gunpoint and we have not that was the
last she ever saw of her husband and
then a month later because he he was
wealthy was this here in the Philippines
and there's no divorce in the
Philippines so he paid for her marriage
to be annulled and she was just like my
savior and they had my sister and I like
soon after and they stayed together even
when he lost his money she was his
caretaker at the end of his life and it
really subverts the whole white man
going to the Philippines to find a hot
wife narrative subverts it because there
was real love like and she stayed to the
better that's to my point I mean not you
know if he were 75 it'd be like all
right but a young 50 and uh this circle
crazy circumstances and all like okay I
mean it doesn't have to be predatory
necessarily it's just it's just there's
an imbalance
yeah it's just an imbalance there but it
sounds like they made it work they did
make it work and she still wears she's
been with my stepdad for 20 years now
she still wears his wedding ring so
there is a deep deep like love and
affection there I just always felt like
every time I say it out loud I'm like
was my dad a [__] he was a horny
Predator well the horny but Predator not
necessarily that's where you get it he
like creampied her when he was 60 to
make me
they're just a cream pie aren't you a
little girl I'm an old man [__] high
five yeah
except you know what I'm thinking about
like I my dad was who I thought every
time he like didn't if I would be like
Dad and didn't answer I was like dad's
dead like that's how old I thought he
was
he was 41 when he had me so if I have
kids I'm gonna be the age my dad was
when I was like this decrepit crusty old
man no it's true I would put a mirror
under my dad's yes oh yeah I would check
for him I would chuck his under his nose
how old were you at how old was he at
the time
um he was in his 70s you were like
you're adult almost yeah he died in 2003
and he was 79 so like he was born in
1924 like this man was old yeah yeah
I've never known him to be anything but
old I guess yeah and then people like
when when he would come visit me in
school or pick us up like is that your
great grandpa not even Grandpa it was
great great grandpa is this an elderly
man you've adopted and bring food to
when I first moved to LA and was always
having car problems and like as when
it's like AAA called me and they're like
make sure you call your grandfather he's
really worried about you and I was like
I don't have a grandfather oh my dad
you're like my grandfather got a long
time ago I remember like my last
grandparent died when I was I think 15
which I was like oh my God I can't
believe I got a grandfather for this
long and then like you see people that
are our age and they're like my grandma
passed away and you're like you have a
grandparent yeah yeah like this is just
such different times of their lives
their parents had them I don't know if I
said this to you last time I think I
said it to you but I have a very strong
feeling that EMDR would help you like a
very strong
would help you process the really
access stuff like that in a way that you
never had before and integrate it with
in a different way okay and I would look
at it from a different place MDMA myself
you can do that but but EMDR which is
the eye movement therapy yeah yeah I I
really have this strong feeling that
that would be very helpful do you have
someone I do I do yeah I was I just had
this like flash like oh this would be
perfect now is it so what it is is it's
like is it moving like the parts of your
brain you're using it is it is it is
it's kind of a hypnotic technique right
so you're it's releasing a part of your
brain to allow it to connect to the
other parts you're not wired up properly
when you've had certain traumas or
certain parts of yourself are left
behind it takes I wasn't therapy for 11
years to hook that all up EMDR makes
that much quicker it's a much faster way
of doing it and so it's a very intense
way of getting at things that your brain
doesn't want to get near or doesn't want
to it won't sit hold it and experience
it the way it always has and to go into
it in a real way and get at it and you
know examine it it's hard it's hard and
EMDR lets you do that and it's intense
it's an intense experience you've done
it well I did
um brain spotting and I it was a very
very uh I took a couple days for me to
come down from that and it was I felt
really kind of traumatized by it
actually that's not well done or not
well chosen for you I realized that soon
after they never saw her you shouldn't
be traumatized but you can feel kind of
like you saw something's wrong like
something's this is like not supposed to
feel like this that's a common feeling
but you are because you're getting
you're accessing the party stuff your
brain doesn't want you to access for me
it was like I I was like stuck for 45
minutes and I was dry heaving like
vomiting and I didn't really say much I
was like locked in a place that was
really you're going to be driving just
do I lost so no this is really
interesting because everybody's going
we're gonna bore everybody's shitless
with this one but but
um they are I think what you were in is
something that sometimes referred to by
some theorist as trauma-associated dead
spots
like where you you go into it and you
you Avo it's such a dead zone that it's
actually a source of anxiety and it and
it's in you and you you're able to walk
into it because of these processes and
when you're in it you literally go into
like a Fugue state do you think that's
what it was did time change time
contract or expand or anything yeah I
just I was just stuck like the no words
should come out so are you thinking
about it I feel like worked up so I used
to go into those spots in therapy too
I'd fall in them all of a sudden I'd be
like and then I'd sit there and the next
thing I would know the therapist would
go that's the end of your time and I
would have no idea crying yeah it's
intense I forgot she was in the room I
forgot what I was doing yeah so but it's
it isn't the more you can go into those
spots and tolerate them they just go
away oh is it like similar to Parts work
like is it a part of yourself you're
fine like ashamed of or something it's
not it's it's literally I don't know
what it is just a memory of something no
it's it's a um
probably it's some sort of residual of
trauma right and remember I I can't
remember all we talked about last time
but did we talk about freezing the
freeze response I think so yeah so when
you're really traumatized you go into
these you go you die you die inside you
you you're preparing for being being
eaten or whatever that's what our
brain's body does so we so we dissociate
we can we go out of our body we can look
overhead or we shut down or we're
looking down a tunnel or something all
that is your body shutting down
preparing for the worse preparing to be
killed surrendering to death yeah it's
it's and it's called and it's it's it's
powerlessness and it's you know it's
dissociation and it leaves these
dissociative sort of dead regions that
some people start to use as a way of
regulating their emotions and then
because sort of gets integrated in very
dysfunctional ways but others of us
myself is just a source of just longing
and anxiety and sort of longing for it
to end and longing to reconnect to
something where that didn't exist and
anxiety so is it useful for me to keep
revisiting those dead spots I I don't
know I can't advise you because it was
so traumatizing but it just wasn't
explained to me like yeah whatever it is
that was too big a dose
okay and maybe there are other ways in
that are gentler and the dose is less
intense and so you can tolerate it and
let it slowly it'll go away oh that's
good to know yeah yeah a little hope
um I wanted to ask you about sexual
imprinting and I know it can be a little
like controversial for some people
um but does the sexual trauma let's say
for instance Annie and I endured dictate
sexual preferences
um in our life or like yeah I definitely
do not [__] white guys with the dreads
all right you took that from me you took
that from me but as you know you can
avoid too you can go into an avoidance
strategy thing but that is what I want a
white guy with [__] dresses it has to
right yes for example I have
um a friend of mine or actually more
than a couple of my male friends who've
experienced like
some level of sexual trauma early on by
like a family member they have like uh
they have a lot of Shame around it but
they they reenacted yeah do you know how
many times we've gotten molested It's
like because this is what I this is what
I understand what I've heard you can
tell me if I'm wrong but you like when
you have a trauma when you're young like
that is sexual trauma you you find other
opportunities that are similar like
start out the same way and you go into
them hoping that you're going to work it
through so so
no no it's it's a little more more
specific which is people don't talk
about what trauma does to attraction
right it makes you attracted to people
and circumstances no one knows why this
happens it's irrational the brain is
just this way it makes you attracted to
people and circumstances that are just
like the original trauma and so you can
say that it's a working through process
or your brain can try to make sense of
it that way but the fact is it's this
irrational imprinting as you've called
it you're attracted to somebody that
will oblige you by recreating of course
the same kind of person same
circumstance same thing is going to
happen but you're back to your original
question does it have to be
re-traumatizing no it doesn't like it
can be playful people can use it to
master it and they can get off on it too
and it may always be a preference of
some type okay that's okay but you have
to work through the trauma but is it
okay yeah I don't keep redoing because
because really what happens let's say I
don't know
some you're physically abused in some
way and that becomes sort of a thing you
incorporate into your sexual behavior
yeah it can easily just go just a little
too far and you're retract okay so me
being like a [__] say for instance like
the idea of watching someone that I love
have sex with someone else that rage I
feel is so it the blood goes rushing
into my [__] but I know that I am also
like like my claws are out yeah my claws
are out and there is a level of like I
can almost not take this like I'm trying
to I thought that's what brain spotting
was
but it's like am I is my wanting to be
like cooked yeah so like it is it is
Nikki Glaser had something like this too
she's talked to me about and
[Music]
um
he goes away in therapy because
obviously obviously sad about it you're
like oh no I mean you can play with it
as a fantasy but to actually do it it
just destabilizes relationships yeah
it's so unstable this is the thing where
when we get into these relationships
where we're all being vulnerable we're
vulnerable and so you know you have to
keep it simple and keep it safe and you
if you bring things in that make it you
get to breathe make it rock yeah where
you don't know what feelings you're
gonna develop towards another person or
this or how you angry you're going to
get at the the cuckolding participant
whatever it's all unstable so it all
makes things unravel I cannot be like
older like a couple of minutes I cannot
safely be an experimental [__]
safely be an experimental do you think
you can I really think sometimes I can
but I know what you mean there are some
days where I'm just like I want to
[__] I can't handle it it's a way of
sabotaging yeah I think you're right and
maybe we always talk about stuff how we
self-flagellate yeah and right it makes
it tells you things about yourself that
are kind of not true it's almost like if
I can handle this moment then it's gonna
do away with all the jealousy all the
insecurements I've ever felt no and it
doesn't no I feel like jealousy and
insecure stuff is just self-love right
isn't it just like being like secure in
yourself because even if you do get
cheated on it's like yeah it's
complicated right I mean it depends how
deeply involved you are
self-love me yeah I don't like terms
like that anyway I don't
like that is so you know what I mean
like I feel like anyone well if you
trace everything back it's like this
like it's this like self love like it's
like you're like it's some like deep
insecurity about yourself so I think
more that that the way I re I don't talk
about safe love I talk about being fully
integrated whole and being able to
regulate your emotions well because I
just feel like whatever for me is as
good as it gets if I'm like upset
outward it's usually something I'm not
giving myself because because you didn't
pay attention because you're not fully
integrated right right it's just a party
one getting attention it wasn't present
with you and then I'm triggered because
yeah because so it's really not
self-love it's self-integration itself
you know so there you go [__] did you
like that but um
oh my God who are you
you can do damn our interns
their food being distributed is listen
yes what is so funny if you want to do
[__] like that don't do it
I'm good thank you don't do it thank you
for having that boundary nobody else
okay so go [__] around all you want do
that go do all the craziness but then
real intimacy because that will destroy
it it won't feel cocky if you don't care
and love about the person why did you
point at me when you said you don't care
or love the person love the person I'm
loving okay [__] no she's saying you
couldn't be a casual cuck oh I love you
too deep
how about this oh oh geez what if your
boyfriend what about all those topics up
on the board there they look interesting
I have always felt this one phenomena
that I could never I just always had a
lot of self-blame for whatever until one
of my best friends had the same thing
and I was like there's something to this
and I want to know what you think
but
we were both in a situation where
someone did something bad to us
and rather than acknowledging that that
someone did something bad to us we both
separately in order to cope
pretended like that wasn't the case of
course because we didn't want to ever
see ourselves as a victim right because
what women do to themselves over and
over again is blame themselves for
everything that happens big inventories
how did I do this what did I do that
Lauren Savant is a dear friend of mine
she and I used to do radio together and
she's the Potted Plant lady from
Weinstein and she said when that
happened she immediately went like oh my
God what did I do where did I how did I
give him the idea that and where and why
did I come down here with him and what
did I do and she would kind of over the
years told us about it would laugh about
it but really the whole wow was sort of
taking responsibility for it which was
not okay ladies but there are [__]
[__] out there you didn't do it
right but then on top of that with the
self-blame it was it's like
it did it it's like it is it's all
self-blame but it's also
I could I would never let that happen to
me but but anyway that would never have
happened to me so clearly but that's
what I'm that's the coping is I'm like
right that's that's the way of avoiding
powerlessness right yeah so you you
we're maintaining control over it I
still I was the one that caused it
therefore I'm not powerless yes what the
what that's normal but also I think
what's missing from this too is like are
you doing a lot of stand up right now a
little bit why I just feel like
that you you need to feel more powerful
you need to stand up and own the crowds
and stuff if that makes sense yeah I
mean yes there'll be good practice it
would help you master those feelings of
not wanting to feel powerless well I'll
say this like that the specific thing
I'm talking about was years ago and it's
not really on my mind a lot but it was
just recently brought up because someone
had said the exact same thing where
they're and I'm not saying and I'm
really not I'm just reacting yeah yeah
okay I
need to step into like and feel powerful
I'm not sure quite exactly what I meant
by that but I thought as you were
talking I thought I bet stand up might
fulfill that it popped up that's
interesting I've been reading a lot of
books on leadership lately so maybe
there's something going on yeah you know
when you guys do stand-up it's that's a
crazy thing you're standing in a room in
front of a microphone a little stand in
front of everybody telling stories about
you know crazy vulnerable [__] and if
they don't if you don't get the right
reaction you're you die you die up there
you know I mean think of it while you
kill I know the words the words we use
for people that's funny you either kill
or you die yeah well I guess what I
wanted to say like not to not to take
away from this but because you had said
this on annual too like it's like you
like where women take on this like blame
or whatever but there is also I think
like so much societal blame like when
when
ever I've come out with something it's
like I get like attacked like I did do
something when I come out with something
that has been done to me I get attacked
and it's I guess it's like I'm trying to
get strong enough to just like not even
hear those voices who that's always so
bizarre to me when there's so many
things about human behavior
that when people sort of react to it
just I just I can't even believe it yeah
and this is one of those things yeah
it's it's so pathological right like
that but just you're gonna have to see
it as that it's pathology and then I
think it's like because like maybe we do
have an innate thing to like run
inventory on ourselves and what we did
to kind of feel more like responsible
because that feels but I think that is
too that I think it's twofold I think I
think women do that to themselves like
regardless they just take responsibility
for everything I don't know if that's
society or wiring yeah do that and it
has the secondary motivation of avoiding
powerless yeah if it's in a situation
where you're powerless but you do that
with everything women do that with
everything they take it all on and it
and then and then destroy each other
yeah which is just like
not never here yeah never in this
sanctity of this
maybe out there though
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of you
because when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything that
life throws at you and look I mean this
is a very good episode right to
highlight how much mental health has
helped all of us and working on
ourselves there's just no way there's
just no way in hell I could have gotten
to the place I am today without therapy
in the last 15 years of my life like
I've been in therapy since I was a
teenager it is the one indispensable
part of my life and it has helped me
heal it has helped me kind of just
cope with all the hard stuff and if
you're thinking of giving therapy a try
better help is a great option no one can
do this on their own and I'm I'm saying
that to myself because sometimes like I
think oh you're such a baby because you
can't get through things by yourself no
we all are born to like get help and
have community and like we just we need
each other and sometimes that each other
is a therapist and an unbiased ear yeah
and also it's like if you're anything
like me my ego does not want me to do to
do this anyway so if there's anything
put in the way like parking or they
don't take my insurance or I can't get
an appointment when I want one I will
just completely ignore it yeah our egos
don't want us to get help so there's a
million excuses there to not do it
you're not alone with that if you want
to live a more empowered life therapy
can get you there visit betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday today to get 10 off your
first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday
let's talk about Special Forces let's
talk about my special forces yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah Dr Drew's career no no
not my career just the crazy thing I did
in the water move of his whole life even
before I saw you on the screen when they
first presented it I was like I just
know Dr Drew is going to be on no I saw
you that is weird because I think I'd be
the last person
yeah it's like guess what it's like
conquer fear Central it's like it was
like it was so I was feeling old I had
like I prostate out and I was having
Diverticulitis and I was when you know
covet kicked the [__] out of me and I
was just feeling kind of weird and old
and whiny and I don't know I wasn't
happy I couldn't get traction with
anything and they called me with this
thing I'm like oh come on you're it's a
joke right yeah like where you taking me
Utah or something they go no Jordan I'm
like Middle East how do you do that and
uh in the event uh I said let me think
about it I went out and I started
training like really training like
running hills and packs on and stuff and
I started feeling really good I thought
oh maybe this is what I've been looking
for so I said I'm going I'll do it I put
two weeks of real serious effort into it
was getting up at five in the morning
and doing the whole thing and um I had
my ass handed to me out in the desert
but ended up with great friends Jamie
Lynn Spears saved my life in the in the
desert literally because I became
encephalopathic I I got such bad heat
stroke and dehydration that I didn't was
out of my head and she grabbed me and
took me to the medic oh that must have
been good for her she's been through
some weird [__] she you know she said
something that was so heartbreaking to
me she we love her she's delightful yeah
I've been I've spent time with her I
like her husband a lot he's a great guy
I spent time with her and her kids and
we literally spent a weekend together
and she's like Mom she's a delightful
one and um
what was I going to say about this oh
she said we we gathered for some PR one
day and she goes you know I really don't
have friends she goes I've lived this
life you know so we've all been sort of
Walled off by things and this you're my
new family I thought wow yeah and
somebody like somebody else in the group
said that too and Nastia Lucan sort of
said that and I was like wow this is
amazing that we all ended up so close so
it was a Hannah Brown too was on it
right though Amazon Mel was on it uh Mel
says the same thing Mel says the same
stuff so well yeah I guess like Fame is
it's isolating well in that level you
know when your sister is Britney Spears
and you're she was a you know she was a
child actress and all this stuff and uh
I guess and Mel too right Mel's been a
Spice Girl for how long and also being
on well she's on Nickelodeon wasn't she
Jamie Lynn yeah I mean and that's
traumatizing in his life I mean that's
[__] up right now
so Danny's oh that's scaramucci
scaramucci had a rough week last week I
called him and tried to talk him out of
it he feels very bad about the way he
was portrayed I know that's hard he's a
great guy guy he's a great guy we all
love him now have you because you have
been like the producer of a lot of
reality shows and stuff was it hard for
you to be like a guest on it no not at
all because because it's the way I think
reality should be done which is you
create an intense circumstance where
[__] will go down and just let the
cameras roll that I so agree that's the
preferred that's like big brother-wise
it's so good exactly it's just real
[__] goes down [__] goes down to
treatment always what about Teen Mom you
did too right still do that oh you do
it's still oh my God's still very
interesting the babies are having babies
now well we're almost there wow yeah
congratulations
now that show I got like triggered by
was my boyfriend's brother's really into
it and he was like you guys got to watch
it because we love reality TV and I
watched one of the earlier I think it
was one of the earlier seasons and the
girl was like pushing her mom and I just
like could not deal with parent abuse so
I had to like I think so yeah I couldn't
well there was actually a lot of weird
kind of physical domestic stuff I like I
don't know the physical stuff I was like
I cannot because I always fall asleep to
TV so I look at it like if I wake up in
the middle of the night am I going to be
school speaking of falling asleep do you
guys watch tar that movie is that Cate
Blanchett yeah not yet I I we had to put
it on three different times because we
kept falling asleep did it ended up
being good
I was fascinated by it I have a hard
time calling it good well let's talk
about it's like the pacing of something
so oh my God it's like I totally we fell
asleep three times and and it was it was
courageous how about that for a good
word for the director and the and Kate
Blanchette but the story was I mean it
was you know it was boy in the Frog I
kind of liked that but I would have
loved more music like it's about a
composer I would have loved more music
triangle of sadness yet no that's what
the show is called new name it was like
three hour movie though right it's like
really long it's not that long but it is
so [__] good okay I'll go see it it's
just really kind of like what happens in
this situation and I always love when
like Filipinos rise and they're so good
there is a character there her name's
Abigail that just makes me so [__] she's
the most badass [__] I've ever seen on
do you want to see her boyfriend [__]
her I do I just want to watch
[__] I actually do and you know what
that's not so far off from like I know I
haven't seen the movie did you see it
maybe you're actually gay and we just
don't know it yeah you have to get it
all the way hooked up I tried going
after a date with a girl it was lovely I
just felt no um the juice is Flowing
yeah but I do I have I had um
experiences with women that have been
fun but usually in the context of like a
threesome and more like an accessory to
yeah yeah have you ever won a [__]
outfit and watched
but I've never I I tried going down a
girl once or twice actually same girl
not different
um and wasn't really wasn't I didn't
feel like it was a sport for me yeah
yeah but it might be because you didn't
have a strong connection because you
said earlier so you think your [__] is
going to be the one I just think you
said that you need a connection with
someone you're right it is so odd to me
I wonder if it's the way we're all
constructed at the present moment but
how much the genitalia themselves are
deterministic and people's sexual
orientation yeah in other words that's
weird like all my gay friends think we
talked about this all my gay friends
like oh vagina oh okay yeah
and a lot of straight women will say
that about right yeah and you're kind of
saying that that's a really good point
it's got to be fair It's gotta be the
smell of it it's just it's whatever it
is but it's weird to me that we should
be just overwhelmingly like put off by
it I guess you know you're right yeah
and I think maybe I might be gay because
I love making out with girls I love the
company of girls I like talking to girls
I like they're just soft and gorgeous to
me but I always said no I cannot be gay
because I can't eat [__] yeah but I'm
like I've been in love with a girl no no
but just but again you think everybody's
in love with it believe me a lot of gay
men say the same kind of stuff too and
it's very deterministic it's like a real
serious version of reference yeah I've
had gay friends where we make out but it
never goes like below the belt but maybe
good but I also offer a lot of like I
always say like the men that I'm
attracted to like I love half gay boys
is what I always say because if a guy is
pretty open or open with me about having
had experiences with men I I kind of
used to call halfmo
I love watching a half Moen slo-mo
well it turns me on and it makes me
think oh this person's so sexually open
not restricted by their genitalia and
sexist do you like watching them make
out guys I don't kind of care I used to
in high school I I mean in college I
used to always make my boy I had this
one beautiful gay friend who was just so
cute and so lovable like and I would
always Dan Gower would always be like
make out with I like loved I got off on
the power of them like my [__] just got
wet I know I've been making out with my
interview with these little shorts that
were so cute but I do watch gay porn
foreign
men and women I watched anything
anything that involves any type of
touching Island you don't have to go
into extreme stuff no no no what's
extreme well I don't know you know do
you need more and more sort of imagery
that's more intense no as of lately I've
I've been trying to learn to uh
masturbate to remember memory only and
um because I'm trying to cleanse the
palette of the 4K porn stuff that I've
been indulging you were saying that you
were saying to me the other day when I
was talking to you that you that women
are more like listen to like erotica I
said that women it's not it's not a
universal thing but men generally like
uh Stormy Daniels said this to me she
she she used to come on Loveland back in
the day really and she went from
performing to producing and directing
these films and one day I was
interviewing her for something and she
goes look I produced a ton of these
films I produced them for men and women
and I learned with absolute Clarity what
the men want and what the women want the
men want to see people having sex the
women want to know why those two people
like each other so much that they want
to have sex and she goes I have to have
the story and the end is going to be
some injury and some of this and some of
that before it's sort of that is I was
watching the Buccaneers game with uh
with my with Josh Potter and with my
boyfriend Todd and they were like
getting all into the the game and
everything and I was going like do you
think Tom Brady's like upset about
Giselle still like I was Googling his
ex-girlfriend I was like how old is his
kid we were just like laughing so I was
being such a girl about the [__] game
wow but they didn't now that I've like
read up more on it like they didn't
break up because of football it was like
the FTS right yeah but he funny thing
but I got it because then they lose how
much they lose Carlos I want to look it
up like it's in the millions yeah it's
hundreds of millions but that's but this
is something that she said don't do it
and he did it anyway kind of thing could
have he lost 70 million dollars yeah
that's not he probably is worth that's
not 400 million though right I mean no
maybe but you know worth more than him
but I was thinking about oh was it her
money how could you know how could any
of us have any idea why they broke up
realistically right yeah why are you so
giggly about it because we talked about
this last week on last week's episode of
we had Katie Morton on oh I love Katie
yeah relationship needs lots of time
they just do and if you don't have that
I mean when you're ready yeah when
you're raising a family everybody
understands it's all hands on deck but
in terms of when there's opportunity to
spend time together you got to spend
time together I just learned that over
and over and over again I really like
what you said earlier which is you got
to keep relationships simple and safe
it's people need a simple life now you
can mess around with that but you do it
at certain risk were you on that show
too a simple life yeah I don't think
so have it on DVD did you did you work
both you are a merge of both of them do
you have footage to show them of the of
this the uh the trailer or anything of
the bullsh yeah Special Forces because
it was I would love to do that that's
like my dream to do that it's so rude I
feel like this that show is for you I
would love to do it get me a little more
famous guys so we can do that sign it up
in the ICU oh my God I see you yeah yeah
did you go into like rhabdo or something
well that's what I that's what I thought
I thought I could like because I keep
going in and out of Consciousness and I
got so sick so fast like within an hour
I was like I couldn't think and couldn't
walk and uh and I kept trying to figure
out all night how you know what might
have happened they made me so sick so
fast sorry and I had a calf injury going
into this thing and I thought maybe I
blew the muscle and got some rhabdo and
so in the morning
I had so many crazy experiences in the
hospital I had to manage my own fluids
you know it was crazy but he's so
grateful to be a doctor do you think you
would have been yeah I don't know what
happened it's hard to imagine and Kate
Kate gossing was in the room next to me
because she fell out of the helicopter
and hurt herself and oh [__] oh yeah
[__] oh yeah her big vagina didn't bite
her down no parachute vagina yeah and uh
and she's a nurse she's an RA so she was
fighting stuff off too oh wow so they
wanted to take me to the operating room
and all kinds of crazy [__] and they
were like no it's like you're not
operating I mean no no and
um in the morning this attending comes
in there with full military guard
Raspberry Beret epaulettes big brass
buttons you were severely dehydrated
there were these things called
electrolytes
get me the [__] out here I just gotta
get out of here and uh and then I heard
he broke into Arabic and I heard the
word CPK and I and I said hey did you
measure CPK yeah California Pizza
California Pizza bathroom
yeah it's something that releases from
released from muscle and massive
quantity during rap doing so it'll be a
sign of round what's rhabdo it's just
massive muscle breakdown because then it
gets then clogs the kidney and your
kidneys fail and it can cause fluid
imbalances yeah it's pretty nasty you'll
be it's pretty crazy they blew us up on
the train we ran we had no idea what's
going to happen all of a sudden the
train blew up it's like it's um how much
did you have to sign when you went on
that's the thing I mean you could die
you could die you could die okay here we
go you know normally you just think
that's just perfunctory you know of okay
if something bad happens but this is
like no they meant it I'm such an
adrenaline junkie like that yeah but
this is you're you're so
it's like yeah it's pushing you beyond
like Beyond you ever thought yeah and
they're just yelling at you in any
little move and they start screaming at
you and then they punish the group if
one person you know gets out of line
were there a lot of water stuff their
water experiences like the water
challenge yeah there were as much water
in the Red Sea but hang out what was I
talking about before hospital so it was
hospitalized to see I heard the word CPK
and I go hey did you measure my CPK and
he goes no we didn't I go I was trying
to figure out why I got six so maybe I
have rhabdominalis he goes oh everybody
rob De Milo says my patient knows my
business
it sounds like it's part of the show
they're like roasting you and I didn't I
did not tell them I was a physician I
just did not let that out and uh so I
thought I just could I thought your
first name was Doctor yeah just get out
I said get out so I left and that was
that
um but anyway they never even measured
yours you they just they did not but by
that point I did five liters of IV fluid
and I could stand up and walk and I
thought it was a pretty good also cool
anyway but anyway there we were yeah
wait so what were your takeaways
takeaways for the rest of your life
takeaways were that
um so so as I told you I was feeling old
so guess what I learned I learned like
animals
under the face pressed to the mirror
with the limitations of it and I'm fine
with it because I'm really pretty good
for my age yeah I'm I'm lucky in a lot
of respects and so I felt great
photography have you seen the shirtless
pictures Jesus hello accepting of where
I am fully and that so I like God
received the other thing is that how
powerful relationships get in extreme
circumstances when you're in misery and
in trauma man it was because of each
other that we got through this thing we
were bonded up like that did you blame
anyone were you guys like blaming the
production and stuff are you pissed at
people there was no splitting no
splitting it just splitting started a
little bit later like right around now
on the show if you watch it'll be a
little splitting going to splitting
splitting means he's good she's bad this
one's getting special favor she is and
why do why did you do that you know just
a lot of blaming and it's called
splitting behaviors rather than Unity
you're always better when you're unified
so but there's some splitting shows up
and it when people are stressed there's
inevitably splitting and you see that in
all of the shows you work on pretty much
splitting yeah
well whenever so so splitting develops
when there's either a Psychopathology
like borderline is notorious for
splitting drug addicts notorious for
splitting or extreme stress and reality
is both right a lot of Psychopathology
and a lot of extreme circumstances
splitting ensues so yeah I would love to
go on a reality show that is like
hardcore workouts but not like the one
not that scary like I want to see a
shower berries I think I would like to
see a show called Esther does things
it's just exposure therapy all the
things that you're you know it's very
basic things yeah like Barry's boot camp
again instead of drinking all their
smoothies right you actually do a
workout or like you know swimming in a
pool and learn like to swim learning we
call it a bite yeah we called her um her
one of her Predators from berries her
old uh Barry's instructor became friends
with him oh yeah on one of the epis
early episodes she was traumatized by a
Barry's boot camp um class that she took
and she how many classes did you buy
before oh yeah you went in hard I bought
a 50 class pack and I was only able to
fulfill about three and I asked if they
could exchange it for Smoothie points
no and he was so funny the teacher
called him and just like you lazy
[__] pretty much it was funny he was
great because the instructor that she
was terrified of in Barry she didn't
even tell me his name I was like let me
guess it's Kyle because Kyle is my
favorite because he's very like
authoritarian I just like tell me what
I'm supposed to do and I don't need a
lot of Praise I just need to know that
like I'm getting my bang for the buck
which is I'm here to work out and die so
that's what I'm getting you would not do
well on this show no no you would so you
want to do yeah maybe faster version I
would I would it would be like the
sleepovers when I was a little kid can
you come get Mom come get me because
they just scream at you constantly
constantly wow it would break her though
because you get through it probably I
don't know you'd be calling lawyers
though you would be funny you'd be like
tearing up contracts you said that you
don't need a lot of Praise And I'm just
curious because I'm going through this
like phase in my life where I want to do
what I've been calling the reassurance
challenge like where I go 10 days
without seeking any reassurance from
someone
and I'm just curious like I I feel like
everything I bring up you're just gonna
be like you need EMDR and severe therapy
oh no no the other get up on stage and
just eat suck it up like take the take
the take the punches but that I can do
like I can go bomb like it's nobody's
business and then I can walk off and be
great but I do need a lot of like
validation and like I mean we'll do that
and then don't get any validation
afterwards right yeah but you know I try
to find my praise like somewhere else
it's not that I don't need praise I
wasn't given praise when I was younger
yeah
um because my mom was somebody who was
bullied beaten humiliated her whole life
so when she had us the praise that my
sister and I got from being like you
know swimmers all of these things she
took for herself and she doesn't she
wasn't going to share it with us so the
expectation was for us to just this is
Baseline Behavior you just have to be
good that's Baseline you have to be fast
that's Baseline and you're not going to
get get anything from me if you don't do
that you get beat
that's it so like but but I do like
praise I just kind of find it not in the
moment of like exercise or because I'm
used to not receiving it at that moment
I see it's specific to that yes and so
remember we talked about how some things
are not all good and all bad that's a
good adaptation of a bad situation yeah
but that's good that you can put it to
good use yeah
like when my my trainers are like hard
on me but also like at the end are like
show me a little pride they're like you
did it or whatever I like both yeah a
little bit I like being told like I
don't like to be let off the hook like I
don't like when they're like oh are you
tired you know what's really fun is
praise that comes out of nowhere like
when you're normally you're normally
getting beaten up by the person all of a
sudden they say something like specific
and yeah it's like oh my God I can't
believe right I'm eating it up well
Chelsea Handler I used to do her show
and I didn't know her beforehand at all
I just got booked on the show through
Michael Cox on the round table yeah on
the round table and I did it a bunch I
did it for like a year and a half did we
ever do it together no it would have
been weird but it was like every three
weeks I would do it that's me too and
she um I never had like a relationship
with her and it would be like because I
think I was like basically an open mic
or this was like my big break they were
basically like don't look in the eye
don't do any other there that's kind of
the way she is yeah yeah but sometimes
she would be like hey girlie and she
would like tickle me on the summer like
oh my God like I literally like I would
like follow her around and then other
times she'd be like yeah yeah yeah and
I'm like oh my god did you not invite me
or like what how did I get in the
building I had to go through all
security and it was always and I have no
relationship with her now I'm very
grateful to her because it's like
unbelievable she gave me that
opportunity I mean I was just like
really like two years into comedy at
that point and I'm and I was just like a
young boy like well she had crass blonde
like why did she she didn't have to put
me on there and it was really cool but
you know I just yeah I always have like
a little thing about her now that's her
favorite flavor of comic I think yeah
Chelsea if you're watching miss you
happy on our show we love you
um Dr Drew thank you so much for joining
us oh my God is it already over that
went so fast we didn't talk about any of
that [__] on the panel that's been there
for years for years yes you feel as
compassion fatigue this last time no I
don't feel it no no no no we've grown
not at all because last time we really
were talking about trauma trauma trauma
trauma you know and we injected some
[__] and penis into this one yeah we
did get yeah we got a little more
sexuality okay Gosling I'm sorry about
that parachute joke
um I stand by it and Kate Kate is again
also a dear friend the whole group just
I love that that's good friends and
she's amongst them and just yes can't
see enough good about everybody I'm so
happy for Jamie Lynch because I feel
like she's been through so much [__]
with all the stuff with her sister she
can yeah I know and she and the stuff
she said if you that first episode it
was the second episode where she was
talking about what it's like to grow up
when your sister becomes the most famous
person in the world like it's intense if
she didn't say I resent my sister or her
it's just like it just felt it was to
deal with it's probably similar to like
when your sibling has special needs or
something just someone that gets like a
lot of attention it's just yeah it's
just a lot and it's going to bleed over
onto everybody and she doesn't you don't
blame the person who's getting the
attention you just it's your experience
and it was intense and I guess for her
as I think about it the one thing that
she maybe she doesn't know yet is that
the fact that she doesn't have any
friends that's a big deal for a young
girl yeah not to be able to have friends
and she's lovely yeah so oh
I could talk to you guys all day yeah
and Jamie Lynn we're your friends not to
be weird we're your friends come hang
out with us you'll have to come back and
everyone will check out your show yes oh
so okay so my offer killed me if I don't
if I don't yeah promote this so um we do
a streaming show I had to postpone it an
hour today in fact because uh to do this
but Tuesday Wednesday and Thursday at
three o'clock at Dr drew.tv check it out
on Wednesday particularly we do a very
popular controversial show where I am on
another peer another an ER physician
named Kelly Victory and she has a lot of
very strong feelings a little different
than me in terms of treatments for covet
and how the facts a lot of stuff we just
read a lot of things but she and I have
been interviewing all of the people that
have been canceled during the covid so
Malone and names like that McCullough
people you may have heard of we we go
through the hits but we go through
everybody about acharya and we just we
talk to them all and some of them their
ideas like yeah I kind of get they're a
little bit I don't agree with them but
every single one of them I've walked
away with some sort of significant
headline about the pandemic that I
didn't know let me just give you a
simple one a guy named Paul Alexander
was at the CDC in the NIH when they were
trying to figure out what to do to you
know mitigate you know you use
non-pharmacological mitigation of the
pandemic the term social distancing was
made up
and six feet was just pulled out of a
hat wow no evidence for it no they were
trying to decide between 10 feet and 60
feet and they didn't feel it but they
will get people to comply with 60 feet
zero evidence at any utility imagine it
was 60 feet I know while we're on this
like the thing that I feel like has
changed my life forever in my
relationship with literally government
and like power forever is that there was
that brief moment in time where everyone
told us not to wear masks and that has
really taken my faith in the Rock too
yeah so so there were I've learned a lot
of things that were going on like that
whereas Shenanigans going both ways and
still underway to this day where they
would they would determine a policy
based on almost nothing and then just
cling to it like it was God's word and
this is not good in today's world where
maybe that was good their playbook was
the AIDS pandemic where I admired
everything they did I was I was part of
that it's why I got involved with Radio
Anthony fauci was telling us you got to
go out and tell people they're going to
get AIDS so that was why I got involved
in Loveline one of the reasons and um
and the Playbook was use fear simplify
messaging repeat it over and over again
don't worry about the details and that's
what they did this time too and that's
not good in a social media World in a
24-hour cable news world that is the
wrong move the move now is transparency
explain spend your spend whatever time
necessary to let them know what your
thinking is and they just refuse to do
that and now they're refusing to look
back and acknowledge for the mistakes
were made and they're becoming
increasingly obvious so anyway if you
have any interest in all that stuff
um we get into all of it we get
everything vaccines not vaccines Mass
not mass and how it all evolved in the
history of it and and the the excesses
the excess more trustworthy than someone
who is able to go back and say okay I
was wrong about it oh my God I I that's
I mean that's how else do we not make
the same mistakes again I know when
someone doubles down that to me is like
okay you're out you're coming let's get
everybody in the government right now
and it's it's very disappointing to me
and that's scary like I would rather
someone be like we don't know everything
we're doing our best
you know and we're gonna make mistakes
some of it is they they became so
religious whenever a doctor is an
evangelist or a scientist an evangelist
run they that's how we got the opioid
epidemic if you really look at the
opiate epidemic how he played out and
how covet played out exact same Playbook
I mean it was exact same phenomenon
happened but you always find some Rogue
evangelists in there that get control of
the regulators and the state societies
and the governors and then it's on and
then anybody that says anything
different gets crushed and ruined
because all these these organizations
are there to do that and it's it was a
bad bad time I had to do without the
opioid crisis I was being sanctioned by
everybody why because my heroin addicts
who had little unhappy faces when I did
their pain assessment and I wasn't
willing to give them an opiate yeah how
cruel yeah literally I was sanctioned by
everybody for that wait okay A little
bit of a shift but because it's like not
trusting government I recently had this
conversation with my dad
that like blew my mind and changed
everything about like how I looked at
his life he basically like the first I
don't know five ten years of his adult
life he was dodging the Vietnam draft oh
stay with my stepdad yeah he's a draft
Dodger that's how we end up in the
Philippines probably
um no this was my stepdad this is how he
ended up Canada
um everywhere else but here like so he
became a school teacher and so did my
stepdad where he started he became a
teacher you have the same step dad
my dad
actually because he's he's Jewish
they're very similar yeah same guy but
like I just can't believe the trauma
that that must have caused on my dad in
effect personally that the first like
majority of his adult like adult was
like hiding from the government yeah
yeah but because he didn't believe in
the war my dad went and then the guy
yeah he went to Vietnam he was in the
Army and the guy he sat next to when
they were flying over was the first
person to die like his friend had just
made Jesus and my dad doesn't really
talk about it that much like I'm sure
there's like a lot of trauma in there
PTSD but but but don't be too I mean I
was around in those days and the the
sort of the you know there was a lot of
what was called uh generation gap that
was actually what was called back then
was generation gap these these guys in
the horion glasses and the white shirt
and the skinny type they can't
understand these kids with the long hair
and blah blah blah the sort of the
heroes went to Canada they were sort of
seen as heroic and then the guys that
went to war were [__] on for going yeah
so there was he must have been awful I
mean he couldn't come home and he's had
to leave his country stuff but it was a
little bit had a heroic kind of I don't
know maybe he didn't go but no no way to
go yeah
this was an unjust war and people who
lived by that and sued against it were
sort of seen as yeah right veterans were
treated basically very poorly with her
her dad was going to treat his [__] she
came back home because it was an unjust
War yeah why did you go and kill those
children
so the real trauma okay that makes sense
yeah people who actually fought are the
ones that happened oh I'm sure that
there's like both sides yeah I'm sure it
wasn't fun you don't like having to run
away but but they were there was this
kind of a positive blush on it at the
time interesting a little bit yeah yeah
so and now now that we've fully brought
everything down we've actually gotten
into war
actually honestly my the the Ken Burns
documentary on Vietnam changed my
[__] life yeah Dr Drew's begging for
us to talk about being molested again no
no no
[Applause]
really really good a couple years ago
that was one of my favorite
documentaries um
um but we should go on tour the four of
us and just call the tour wounds what do
you think oh I love it that sounds like
an ex that's something to sell tickets
the first time you came on the amount of
people who were like wait this needs to
be an actual like show just the three of
you like just pouring your wounds the
amount of like trying to like I was like
is she done is she done
like we're all just like on the edge of
our chairs like but wait wait wait if
we're gonna do this if we're gonna do
wounds around the wounds around America
whatever it might be we'd have to take
questions and stuff too otherwise it
couldn't just be us
you're gonna have to do EMDR you're
gonna have to do the stand up I'm
nervous what do you think I'm gonna find
oh no what do we all do I like that
again it should be should hers I'm gonna
give you a person that won't do what
happened to Lila okay um but but you
know you need to start setting some
boundaries and if you're gonna do the
fun stuff don't do it with somebody
you're involved with a simple and safe
humans need simple we need simple that
we just do I wish I would be how fun
would it be if orgies and polyamory and
all these things were just humans could
just adapt to that and they're thriving
it be fun that'd be great there's a
vanity in thinking that I am an evolved
human I can handle this but it I can
never really there are armies of people
just trying to get two people together
when you bring three and four it's like
that's what the Vietnam War was about it
was a love story it gets very
destabilizing yeah it was just it was
your dad and my dad kissing
well they wrote each other letters the
last episode the main thing I took away
from that was assets and liabilities the
amount of times I've used that and the
time I said that again today yes today
though the two words are safe and simple
yeah I'm walking away with that
so thank you so much thank you so it's
not easy by the way because it's fun
exciting and it's you know and you have
a little addictive kind of thing going
with all the other arousing stuff but
from for for nourishment and Rich lives
keep it simple okay yeah okay cool thank
you wounds my pleasure wounds on the
road wounds around America three gashes
and one guy
three guys
[Music]